Good morning, John.
Earlier this week, Matthew Inman, The Oatmeal, posted a comic about how to get likes on Facebook.
and one of the things that he suggested doing was to create a sing-along video
explaining how to properly load a dishwasher.
And so...
Ooooh
♫This is how you load a dishwasher♫
♫GE, Frigidaire, or Bosch, or
Whirlpool, or any kind of dishwasher♫
♫Well I like to put my cutlery
in the basket facing down♫
♫So my hands never touch the parts
that go inside mouths♫
♫But other folks with cleaner hands
put them facing the other way♫
♫So the jets of water catch them
better with their spray, oh...♫
♫This is how you load a dishwasher♫
♫GE, Frigidaire, or Bosch, or
Whirlpool, or any kind of dishwasher♫
♫Oh, please make sure to check and see if
it's dishwasher-safe♫
♫Because you don't want Tupperware
melting to your plates, and♫
♫Remember to scrape off clumps of
caked-on cheese and fat♫
♫And always check to make sure
that you don't wash your cat, oh...♫
♫This is how you load a dishwasher♫
♫GE, Frigidaire, or Bosch, or
Whirlpool, or any kind of dishwasher♫
♫Oh, heavy things go on the bottom
and the light things on top♫
♫To save water and energy, please fill that sucker up♫
♫And once you've got everything in its proper place♫
♫Insert the detergent,
push the button with your face♫
The sun is gigantic, with a diameter more than four hundred times that of the moon,
However, when you're standing on Earth, the sun and the moon appear to be roughly the same size.
The reason for this is that the Sun is 400 times more distant from the Earth than the Moon,
And thus appears 400 times smaller.
Is this just a coincidence? Yes.
[Fellow Nerdfighters sing along to the chorus]
♫This is how you load a dishwasher♫
♫GE, Frigidaire, or Bosch, or
Whirlpool, or any kind of dishwasher♫
It's a very egotistical day here at Hank Green headquarters,
I've got a Hank Green shirt on,
and a Hank Green drawing,
that I've had since like 2008, and I don't think I've ever put it on my wall.
Neil McMillan, thank you for that.
I'm wearing this today, though, because it's one of my favorite shirts that I ever designed,
and it's on sale FOR FIVE DOLLARS OFF AT DFTBA.COM!
Uuh! Ah. That's…better. Feel way less sellout-y now.
Recently, a slew of teenagers didn't know that the Titanic was a real thing, they just thought it was a movie?
And yes, when I read these things, I feel the same way as you, where I'm just SHOCKED, I'm like
WHAT!?!
It's become a thing about, like, the American education system, but really?
Really? There are a lot of things that twelve-year olds aren't being taught in American schools,
and the sinking of the Titanic is not at the top of my list of additions.
Do they know what the battle of Hastings was, or like why the Magna Carta was important?
Probably not, so my immediate question is why is it that the Titanic thing is a thing that we care about a lot?
Here's why, I think…because the sinking of the Titanic isn't history to us. It's still cultural memory.
It's just one of those things that everybody should know.
But it turns out that twenty of the one hundred million active users on Twitter did *not* know that.
Initially, this is shocking to us because we as humans think that there is a shared cultural memory that we can count on everyone knowing,
but if you think about it for a couple seconds, it becomes clear how extremely unsurprising it really is.
Cause guess what, we're not all born knowing everything.
Pretending like those twenty people are idiots because they, like, lived a different life than I did
doesn't serve any purpose except to, like, maybe make me feel superior,
make them feel horrible,
and also make me, you know, have a little bit less faith in humanity.
All of those things are bad!
John, that's all for today, I imagine that was enough. I'll see you on Tuesday.